okay once you have a particular star but
I'm very attracted to the power of
simplicity I studied graphic design
first and lava academy of my heart after
half a year I realized that the work
died produce it's more to us you know
skill structure and space the project's
one the boss when I first went to the
site that's really bad you know opal and
everything's of concrete and the delay
up ladies I said virtually concentrate
everything on the flats call to hide
everything by doing that basically we
are a free up the space and they can say
enjoy it really and eventually we
actually thought up a big iconic box for
for this home no one would ever know
that what concealed behind is actually
bomb shelter to bathroom I can match
wardrobes and storages with this concept
the next step is on colors we actually
are toying with few colors based on the
most basic materials you know like
plywood cement even gb we opted for a
Vista let laminate we use laminate in
its glossy finishing reason is to
reflect the syrup surrounding and to
make the apartments appear larger than
it is so when you look at the color
scheme wise is basically very
monochromatic its grave black white we
thought oh why not we add some colors in
the cabinet a little give and elements
of surprises a little bit cheeky deliver
we come up with designer is
unconventional and different matters
different way of living owners they
really appreciate the space that we
thing for them the design mental for
them they'll be appreciate that I mean
to keep reminding me not to release the
other out plan I can sense that they are
very proud of their home when the design
stage true from beginning due to the
project complexions these the most
happiest and enjoy moment that I have
you